pov you're an anime fan in 2020 ah
well i'm deep and locked down but the
season's pretty dry i mean i'm gonna be
watching kagia i guess i'll watch tower
of gods but there isn't really anything
else that catches my interest
oh well pov you're an anime fan in 2021
what the hell how is the season so
stacked attack on titan
three zero again look at all these
sequels look at all these other shows
how the hell am i gonna find time to
watch all this
oh well what the [ __ ] is going on with
this season where do i even begin
my 2020 anime of the year re-zero is
finally back to complete its arc promise
neverland is returning with more
toddlers playing 5d chess
b stars egging me on to convert to
ferryism slime 2 is hype so is log
horizon 3. so is euro camp 2 so is 7
deadly
so it sells at work too quincy not on
bureau 2 and on top of
all this we have attack on titan final
season meeting every high expectation we
had and punching
straight past them [ __ ] everything i
said about modern anime classics we are
watching a classic being made
right in front of our eyes and i'm
not gonna be talking about any of those
because on top of all this we still have
the non-sequel shows which by themselves
are enough to match any of the seasons
from last year
this might be one of the most single
packed season of anime in
the history of anime is this actually it
is this
where the 2021 redemption arc finally
[Music]
begins anime is doomed
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen i would like to
welcome you
to the future for years we've been
pushing the limits of computer
technology
as technology evolves so has our
approach
when it comes to keeping on the cutting
edge of animation
reinventing how people see cg
reinventing the shows that uses it
reinventing anime itself five years ago
we gave you berserk 2016.
four years ago we gave you berserk
2017 today
i present to you berserk 2077.
i think we found it guys we found the
best animated
show of 2021. apparently this is an
anime coming from a real studio with
staff members who've never
worked on a single anime before
i'm absolutely shocked i don't think i'm
overstating it when i say
that xr may set a new standard of
animation that will send
ripples in the industry look at this 3d
i haven't seen 3d this clean since
gary's mod was released
which i'm guessing is what it was also
animated in the lip flaps have obviously
been inspired by
dubbed kung fu movies by how accurate
they are they even got my favorite
2000's rock band to do the opening
slink 183 and on top of all this you may
not even notice but in some shots
if you look really carefully you may see
that some characters
don't even inhabit the same dimension
i've seen a lot of people compare this
to ps2 graphics and i don't know why
people would say something
so insulting to ps2 graphics i'd say
this is far more reminiscent of
cyberpunk's stunning visuals
showcasing a futuristic setting and
t-posing
the original trailer boldly said and i
quote declaring war against all sci-fi
series around the world
which as bold as the claim may be i
think also technically constitutes this
as a war crime remember this day
gentlemen
as we are witnessing history this may
actually set a new benchmark
never before seen in anime generations
from now we've been looking back and
saying
remember that time when attack on titan
season 4 was airing
was it really better than x-arm you know
how sometimes the show is just so weird
you have no idea how to describe it so
you're just grasping at straws trying to
find a point for comparison
i've seen people describe this as a
hybrid of about 10 different anime
directed by satoshi yokohara shinkai
onoywasa which just makes it more
confusing and i think they're all
missing the point
because clearly wondered is just the
very first strand thai panel so this
young hooded girl has a casual
conversation with the cicada before
finding some egg seeing a bunch of girls
cosplaying hentai censorship and then
having a full-blown argument with some
talking toilet paper
listen the egg then hatches into a girl
and at this point you're just thinking
damn
i want whatever she's on but as the
episode unfolds you start to get a hint
of what this is actually about we're
peering into a glimpse of a damaged
broken psyche and it's up to us to piece
together what really happened what is
this world
what happened to her why did her friend
jump it's a cerebral tale of bullying
and depression and out of
everything in winter this was the one
that edged its way deepest into me i'm
not gonna pretend i understood what i
watched but what i will say
is that it was the only show i kept
thinking about
afterwards and i don't exactly
understand why i had that slight feeling
that i was watching something that could
blossom into something really special
i still don't know what this is going to
be about but i'm definitely going to
stick around to find out
if it'll be better the next arm
horizontal
i'm in this picture and i don't like it
i'd like to think for the most part that
the anime and manga community are one
and the same but sometimes that comes
along a title that just makes me think
that margaritas live on a different
plane of existence
hori miya was a highly anticipated manga
adaptation that i've never heard
anyone mention or talk about prior so
when all the margaritas scurried out of
their rocks to exclaim their excitement
so i thought it must have a big cult
following or something so i check it out
and
huh it's the 13th most popular manga of
all time on mal
what from the trailer i thought it was
just going to be a serious love triangle
of romance drama and the likes of
toradora but honestly this is just
wholesome as [ __ ] a rom-com about
looking past appearances are never
judging a book by its cover for example
he may look like a straight edge nerdy
student who follows the rules when
really he's a secret bad boy with
tattoos and piercings
and also he's he's he's he's [ __ ] hot
and she may look like the pretty popular
girl in school but nobody knows her
little secret that will change the way
everyone looks at her she's a good
sister
who does chores at home
and she wears her hair in a bun if
that's not gamer enough for you though
we've got
bottom tier character tomozaki following
the top rated player and definitely not
smash bros for all you
real gamers out there a true gaming
anime about a gamer who's really good at
gaming meeting a gamer girl as they
become gamer friends as she teaches him
how to win at the biggest game of all
the game of life gamers and so starts
his training arc as he learns that to be
a true
pro gamer who wins at everything he
first needs to learn
how to lose his virginity as someone who
had zero social skills growing up this
was actually really interesting to me
it's a romantic comedy that breaks down
social interactions and gamifies them
and it's a fun watch if you don't take
the concepts too seriously it's a pro
gamer learning how to function in
society with a cute anime girl teaching
him social skills personal hygiene and
grooming
yes that's right folks this is literally
the uplifting story of a smash player
discovering deodorant you know i feel
sorry for any volleyball anime coming
straight off the heels of high q
especially when it's about the bromance
of an ace duo starring a geniuseto got
pushed out of his previous team because
of a bad attitude because
well it's coming straight off the heels
of high q don't think the high q squad
are worrying too much about bullying
depression and suicide so if you're
looking for a darker edition definitely
keep an eye out for this one
we got the cells at work spin-off cells
at work oh my god i'm black
i actually enjoyed this more than the
original it was way more interesting to
see
cells function in an unhealthy body even
if it did make me feel [ __ ] in my own
lifestyle choices on the upside though
apparently that means having a white
blood cells that gets my cells at work
if you know what i'm saying
i can't believe it's taken this long to
get an actual skateboarding anime and i
can't believe the first skateboarding
anime
is unironically called skate the
infinity with an eight
god if you're gonna do that might as
well just go all the way bring back the
coolest say it's ph
fat because you know what for all these
pretty skater boys
all the girls seem to have said see you
later boy this is coming from the
director of free and banana fish and um
you can definitely tell that there are
definitely a lot of pretty boys along
with gene simmons you've got [ __ ]
lelouchy apparently and our main
character is actually canadian which i
think is great because we finally get
more representation in anime for my
favorite country america 2. that was a
joke canadians it was a cheap stupid
joke i didn't really mean it i know
canadians are nothing like americans you
guys are great
please don't kill me oh what are you
gonna do apologize me to death let's see
what's next why are there children
playing in the road
god damn oh yeah this new easy guy this
season what are you doing
what does it look like i'm doing i'm
taking a leak look away look away
oh come on man right on my book look i
hate spiders as much as the next guy and
i don't need some cheap spider
propaganda showing up in my timeline but
god damn
[Music]
this is a cute little spider i don't
care if you give a [ __ ] about isa cow or
not ow yuki absolutely steals this show
as a girl reincarnated as a spider
i just watched a high practice spider
figuring out how to be a spider for 20
minutes and it was entertaining as [ __ ]
am i about to give best girl to a
[ __ ] arachnid like not even a waifu
guys
sigmund freudian i wanna [ __ ] this
spider but an actual
[ __ ] arachnid oh look it's basically
is it wrong to pick up girls in a
dungeon except the guy is actually
picking up some girls
we got suppose the kid from the last
dungeon boonies moved to a starter town
this is another one of those isocyalis
isakai shows about
wait what's the show about again
oh yeah i don't know why gohans insists
on continuing the handshakers legacy but
they've really outdone themselves this
time
using a literal green screen explosion
effect you can find on youtube giving us
a masterclass and visual coherency not
seen since the likes of ex-arm five
minutes ago remember that one scene from
episode one of goblin slayer that
everyone got super upset and offended
over have you ever looked at that and
thought to yourself
like what if we made an entire show
around that one scene but just 10 times
worse
if you ever needed a reminder that we
live in a post into species reviews
japan
remember that a real human being was
successfully convinced to give
redo of healer an anime adaptation i
think this is the first time i've
watched an
anime and thought to myself i should
probably chill out to something more
vanilla after this how about a bit of
rant izukai harem monogatari perhaps
maybe even something wholesome like
berserk for some light reading it's
beyond edgy
it's everything people got upset about
in goblin slaying shield hero multiplied
to 10
fold it is the prime target to cause an
absolute shitstorm online except this
time i don't think anyone's gonna be
defending it
so all i can say is thank god twitter
thinks attack on titan cg is more
offensive mashoku tensei's light novel
is touted as the grandfather of modern
isokin one of the greatest the genre has
to offer
so as the seasoned isekai trashman my
expectations were high coming into this
and it somehow
met every one of them it's obvious right
from the get-go that this was not
influenced by the cliches of other
isekai but is in fact the progenitor of
them they're not just speedrunning the
death and reincarnation
proper time is put into his life growing
up and learning about this fantasy world
instead of just assuming we know the
ropes already but because of this
there's a level of detail in the world
building and magic systems that aren't
present or are just
glossed over in other isekai the magic
system isn't just controlled water
because this is a fantasy world there's
natural logic and structure behind it
the protagonist is an anti-social otaku
but that doesn't mean he was an otaku
who happened to be
good-looking athletic and just perfectly
built to become a hero he was a fat
stinky ugly bastard who literally gets
introduced jacking off to hentai he's
the ugly truth of what the usual isakai
protagonist should have been
he's flawed he's hella horny he's been
bullied he's been traumatized and this
doesn't all just magically disappear
because he's been reincarnated into a
fantasy world
he doesn't just feel like your typical
vehicle for a wish fulfillment
protagonist but an actual character so
even though we are treading on concepts
we've seen in so many other isakai
before it somehow feels fresh
watching this felt like watching the
godfather after years of only watching
gangster squad after seeing generations
of generations of these concepts being
watered down and turned into tropes and
cliches it was surreal to see the actual
foundations they were all originally
based on this isn't even mentioning the
insane production values that went
into this from the soundtrack to the
animation it can at times feel like a
feature film production
and it's probably the best looking anime
airing this season
so what is presented here feels like an
anomaly this is an isekai that's
reminiscent of all the generic trash
isakai have gorged myself in over the
years but just
genuinely feels like a good show without
any twists or gimmicks in the formula
guys maybe this is the isikai we've been
waiting for
how long has it been how long have those
of us in the isekai garbage dump been
persecuted ridiculed mocked for having
trash
taste just another basic [ __ ] craving a
cheap
escapist pal fancy show with yet another
bland protagonist only there for our
wish fulfillment
but no more my brothers the winds are
changing
times are changing here we could have a
show
a good show that can prove to people
that maybe
just maybe it wasn't so bad after all
maybe there was potential to be seen
that no one else could see
underneath the hundredth overpowered
protagonist in the hundredth fancy world
copying the hundredth rpg
maybe isaka was never meant to be trash
maybe it was meant to be beautiful
exam anime of the season
hey guys hope you enjoyed the video
thank you very much this month
to alpha sigma basil box
elephant joe augustine mike elfin payne
patchett
walter zob mondo ivido and everyone else
on my patreon for making this video
possible and yeah apart from that i've
got no further updates today that's why
i'm not on camera
so i am going to just keep it short and
sweet the season's pretty damn awesome
so
i'm going to go back to watching anime
for once so i've been gigguk and i'll
see you all
next time